Hey, gang, welcome to Smart List. We are a sweet new podcast starring myself, Sean Hayes, Jason Bateman, and Will Arnett, and we are complete idiots. So what we do is we bring on a guest and we ask them stuff, and they make us smarter. Hopefully. It's super cool. So please, come with us, enjoy the show. Okay, so welcome to Smart List.
嘿，各位，欢迎收听《Smartless》。我们是一档全新的妙趣横生的播客，由我本人肖恩·海斯（Sean Hayes）、杰森·贝特曼（Jason Bateman）和威尔·阿奈特（Will Arnett）共同主持，而我们全都是彻底的笨蛋。所以我们要做的就是请来一位嘉宾，问他们各种问题，然后他们让我们变得更聪明。希望如此吧。这真是太酷了。所以请加入我们，享受节目吧。好了，欢迎收听《Smartless》。
Now, Jason, today's guest is your guest, Stacey Abrams, but we recorded this a while ago. So could you just give us a little bit of a timeline on Stacey's interview and why she's airing now? Yeah, we recorded this a few weeks ago and we wanted to hold it so that we could release it a little bit closer to election day because of the ground that we cover. We talk about voter suppression and the election in general, et cetera, et cetera. So the stuff that we don't talk about has not happened or did not happen. Right, because a lot has happened in that time.
那么，杰森，今天的嘉宾是你的嘉宾斯泰西·亚伯拉罕（Stacey Abrams），但我们是前一阵子录制的。所以你能简单介绍一下斯泰西采访的时间线，以及为什么现在才播出吗？对的，我们是几周前录制的，为了配合大选日的时间点，我们想压后发布，因为我们探讨的内容。我们讨论了选民压制和整体大选等等。所以我们没谈到的事情就是还没发生或者当时没有发生。没错，因为那段时间发生了太多事。
Yeah. So apologies for stuff not mentioned, but the future had not happened yet. So enjoy the episode, here comes, guys, we've got a respectable guest with us today. And I'm not going to bore anybody with a bunch of intro nonsense because she need none. Ladies and gentlemen, Stacey Abrams. Whoa. Yeah. Hi.
是的。所以对于未提及的事情在此道歉，因为未来当时还没发生。所以请享受这期节目，我们要上了，伙计们，我们今天迎来了一位德高望重的嘉宾。我可不想用一堆冗长的开场白废话来烦大家，因为她根本不需要。女士们先生们，斯泰西·亚伯拉罕。哇。耶。嗨。
Hi. All right. Oh my gosh. What an honor. This is so cool. Exactly. Tighten up, man. Okay.
嗨。好了。哦天哪。太荣幸了。这太酷了。没错。严肃点，伙计。好吧。
Well done, Jason. Yeah. What a guest. I'm such a huge fan of yours. This is so cool to meet you. Oh, Stacey, this is great to meet you. Well, likewise, I'm fangirling internally. Jason can tell you I can do an IMDB on all of you.
干得漂亮，杰森。耶。多棒的嘉宾啊。我是你的超级粉丝。能见到你太酷了。哦，斯泰西，很高兴见到你。彼此彼此，我内心其实是个狂热追星族。杰森可以告诉你，我对你们所有人的IMDB作品烂熟于心。
So I watch a lot of television. I did have a brief conversation with her about a week ago and she was very, very, very nice. I was surprised. I'm always surprised that anybody knows who the heck I am. It is one of the few good things about being kind of pseudo-famous is that you can kind of cut through the first 12 questions and you can get right into kind of a conversation with someone like at a peer level and you just get right into it. It's a nice-
所以我看很多电视。大约一周前我跟她有过一次简短的交谈，她非常非常非常nice。我很惊讶。我总是很惊讶居然有人知道我到底是谁。作为半红不红的名人，仅有的几个好处之一就是你可以省去前12个问题，直接和某人进行像同行一样平等的对话，直接切入正题。这是一个美好的——
Right, because they're not going like, Jason, now what do you do? Right? Yeah. Right? You haven't had that in a minute. All right. Well, Stacey, I'm really not sure where to begin. Obviously, you're doing the country an enormous service with the amount of work you're doing
对，因为他们不会问，杰森，你现在是做什么的？对吧？对啊。对吧？你已经很久没遇到这种问题了吧。好吧。那么，斯泰西，我真的不知道该从哪里开始。显然，你通过所做的大量工作，为这个国家做出了巨大的贡献，
on giving people the sense or the reality, hopefully, that all their votes are going to count. Right. And for our single listener out there who is not that bright, they're as smartless as we are. That's why they tune in. They want to get less dumb. Can you give them a brief explanation about what your primary focus is every morning now
让人们感受到或切实希望他们的每一张选票都能算数。没错。对于我们那位不太聪明的唯一听众，他们和我们一样一无所知。这就是他们收听节目的原因。他们想变得不那么蠢。你能为他们简单解释一下，你现在每天早晨醒来，
that you're getting up and trying to push the ball forward in this main area of trying to eliminate voter suppression? How can they feel better about the possibilities of that today? How many hours do I have? You've got all the time you want on this. We have nothing left to do today. You're it. First of all, thank you so much for having me, this is a delight.
努力在试图消除选民压制这个主要领域推动进展时，你的首要重点是什么？今天他们怎么能对这种可能性的前景感觉更好一点？我有多少时间？这里有你想要的所有时间。我们今天无事可做。全靠你了。首先，非常感谢邀请我来，这真是太高兴了。
Voter suppression is basically when you are prevented from or discouraged from voting. Typically, it is practiced by an instrument of the government, like, oh, let's say a secretary of state running for governor against you as an opponent. What do you mean? At the top of my head, that's one example. Or it can be a U.S. Supreme Court telling you that you have to go and vote in the middle of a pandemic if you live in Wisconsin or Texas or Alabama, anyway. So voter suppression is when there is an attempt made to throttle your ability to vote.
选民压制基本上就是你被阻止或被劝阻不去投票。通常，它是通过政府的工具来实施的，比如，哦，比方说一个正在竞选州长的国务卿作为你的对手。你什么意思？脑海中浮现的这就是一个例子。或者可能是美国最高法院告诉你，如果你住在威斯康星州、得克萨斯州或阿拉巴马州，无论如何，你必须在大流行期间去投票。因此，选民压制是指有人试图扼杀你的投票能力。
The challenge is that in the 21st century, most voter suppression activities have been perpetrated by Republicans because they find themselves on the losing end of an expansion of who can participate in our democracy. And so typically, the strongest predictor of political leanings is race, which means that whether they think they're racist or not, most of the voter suppression actions are targeted at people of color because we are the most likely to vote Democratic. Their second favorite target are students, and that's why you find voter suppression across the country, but why you find it in New Hampshire, where they passed a law to
挑战在于，在21世纪，大多数选民压制活动都是由共和党人发起的，因为他们发现自己在扩大谁能参与我们民主的进程中处于失败的一方。因此，通常情况下，政治倾向最强的预测指标是种族，这意味着无论他们认为自己是否是种族主义者，大多数选民压制行动都针对有色人种，因为我们最有可能投票给民主党。他们第二喜欢的靶子是学生，这就是为什么你在全国各地都能发现选民压制，也是为什么你在新罕布什尔州能发现它，在那里他们通过了一项法律，
try to disenfranchise student voters. And then the last thing I'll say is this. The architecture of voter suppression is the same no matter where you live. Do they make it hard for you to register and stay on the rolls? Do they make it hard for you to cast a ballot, meaning do they make it hard for you to get an absentee ballot? Do they make it hard for you to get to a polling place because they shut it down? They moved it and didn't tell you.
试图剥夺学生选民的选举权。最后我要说的是这个。无论你住在哪里，选民压制的架构都是一样的。他们有没有让你难以注册并留在选民名册上？他们有没有让你难以投出选票，意思是他们有没有让你很难获得缺席选票？他们有没有因为关闭投票站而让你很难到达投票点？他们换了地方却没有告诉你。
And then the third is, does your ballot count what I like to refer to as Florida? So it is... Right. So it's basically, and it looks different from state to state because we do not have a single democracy in America. We've got 50 different iterations where each state gets to decide how to administer elections. The constitution says you have the right to vote, but it delegated to each state the ability to administer the vote.
第三个是，你的选票算数吗，也就是我喜欢称之为佛罗里达州的情况？所以它是……没错。所以基本上，它在不同的州看起来不同，因为我们在美国没有单一的民主。我们有50种不同的迭代，每个州都可以决定如何管理选举。宪法规定你有投票权，但它将管理投票的能力委托给了每个州。
And so we have voter suppression because bad actors get worse. Good actors sometimes stay okay. And folks who are in the middle look to see if they can win or lose, depending on what they do. And they tend towards voter suppression. I'm a bad actor, I think. I feel like when you said bad actor, you looked at Sean, too. Yeah, definitely.
所以我们有选民压制，因为坏演员（恶势力）变得更坏。好演员有时保持中立。而处于中间立场的人则在观望他们是会赢还是会输，这取决于他们的所作所为。他们往往倾向于选民压制。我想我是一个坏演员。我觉得当你提到坏演员时，你也看了肖恩一眼。对，绝对的。
So let's... You won't say this, so I'll say it. They were obviously successful in what they tried to do in the gubernatorial race. In Georgia. In Georgia. In other words, they knocked a ton of people off that that would definitely have voted for you. You lost by 50,000.
所以我们……你不会说这个，所以我来宣称。他们在州长竞选中试图做的事情显然成功了。在佐治亚州。在佐治亚州。换句话说，他们剔除了大量肯定会投你票的人。你以5万票落败。
They knocked over a million, almost 2 million people off the rolls, right? 1.4 million were purged over time. Wow. So, they were successful there, which is horrific. Can we feel confident that, were that race to be run today, that wouldn't happen again? Have you been successful, at least locally there? And if the answer is yes, have you been able, do you get the sense that you've been successful in other states as well, such that we have less to worry about now than we did back then?
他们从名册上剔除了超过一百万，近两百万的人，对吧？随时间推移有140万被清洗了。哇。所以，他们在那里成功了，这太可怕了。如果这场竞选今天再次举行，我们能确信这种情况不会再次发生吗？你们至少在当地成功了吗？如果答案是肯定的，你觉得你们在其他州也成功了吗，以至于我们现在比当年用不着那么担心了？
I would say we have different things to worry about, but it's getting better. So, there are two ways to tackle voter suppression. One is by actually making the laws work for voters, which is my preference. And so, in Georgia, for example, we faced this thing called ExactMatch. In 2018, 53,000 people had their applications to register to vote held hostage by the Secretary of State. 80% of them were people of color, 70% were black people. We have been able to make strides in reducing the effectiveness of ExactMatch in purging
我会说我们有不同事情需要担心，但情况正在好转。所以，解决选民压制有两种方法。一种是通过实际让法律对选民起作用，这是我的首选。因此，例如在佐治亚州，我们面临着一个叫做“精确匹配”的东西。2018年，53,000人的选民登记申请被国务卿作为人质扣押。其中80%是有色人种，70%是黑人。我们已经取得了进展，降低了“精确匹配”在清洗选民和基本上阻止选民方面的效力。
and basically stopping voters. In 2019, the Secretary of State attempted to purge 309,000 people. We were able to save 22,000 by pointing out that he was doing it wrong. We got another few thousand to reassert their right to vote. And there was a law that was passed that did not apply for some God-forsaken reason to this group, but going forward, you have more time before you get kicked off the rolls. So Georgia is getting slowly better, but they have new ways to do stupid and incompetent. So when you saw the June 9th election, that was sort of a replay of their greatest hits
2019年，国务卿试图清洗309,000人。我们通过指出他的错误，成功挽救了22,000人。我们让另外几千人重新确立了投票权。而且通过了一项法律，由于某种上帝抛弃的原因，它不适用于这一群体，但展望未来，你在被踢出名册之前有了更多时间。所以佐治亚州正在慢慢变好，但他们有做蠢事和无能的新方法。所以当你看到6月9日的选举时，那有点像是他们选民压制“精选集”的重播，
of voter suppression, and they added on top of it the purchase of $100 million worth of machines that didn't work in most counties, and thus you had elections that took a long time. The point is, part of the reason for the work we do is that we've got to figure out for each election what the suppression looks like, but using the primaries helps us get prepared for the general, it's like the dress rehearsal. And so we know both in Georgia and around the country what is going to happen, what's going to go wrong.
而且他们还在上面叠加了价值1亿美元的机器采购，这些机器在大多数县都无法工作，因此你们的选举花了很长时间。关键是，我们开展工作的部分原因在于，我们必须为每次选举弄清楚压制会是什么样子，但利用初选有助于我们为大选做准备，这就像是彩排。所以无论是在佐治亚州还是全国各地，我们都知道将要发生什么，什么会出错。
We know that in Nevada, the Republican Secretary of State shut down every single precinct except for one per county. Except in the county where Las Vegas is located, 80% of Nevadans live in that county. So it's kind of problematic, but we know that. So we can either file a lawsuit about it, we can try to negotiate with the secretaries of state or local elections officials. There's a lot that can be done now that we know what's wrong, and the work that we do through Fair Fight has been getting in there to mitigate the harm during the primaries,
我们知道在内华达州，共和党国务卿关闭了除每个县一个之外的所有投票点。除了拉斯维加斯所在的那个县，80%的内华达人住在那个县。所以这有点问题，但我们知道这一点。因此，我们要么可以就此提起诉讼，要么可以尝试与国务卿或地方选举官员进行谈判。既然我们知道了问题所在，现在有很多事情可以做，我们通过“公正之战”（Fair Fight）开展的工作一直在介入，以减轻初选期间的损害，
but also use the primaries to gather stories and evidence so that we can be prepared for November. And I'm hopeful that November will be better. I mean, wow, first of all, that's so chilling, of course, right, and all of it, any kind of sort of voter suppression is chilling when we look at it now. Obviously, it's been going on for a long, long time, and it must be frustrating just making these small dents in it, but having, you know, continuing on. And my question is, is this something, what I wonder what scares me is, is this something
同时也利用初选来收集故事和证据，以便我们能为11月做好准备。我希望11月会更好。我的天，首先，这太让人不寒而栗了，当然了，对吧，所有这些，任何形式的选民压制现在看都让人不寒而栗。显然，它已经持续了很长很长时间，仅仅在上面取得这些微小的进展一定令人沮丧，但你却一直在坚持。我的问题是，这是一种，我一直在想让我害怕的是，这是一种
that has just gone on sort of unsaid amongst the people who are perpetrating this suppression? Or is there an actual, do you think that there's actual dialogue that happens where they coordinate because it's happening, or is there an actual coordination, do you think, because that's what I think. I think they must be talking to each other and whether it's a, and having discussions about how can we further disenfranchise these people, so whether it's knocking them off the rolls, not letting them off of work, making them vote during a pandemic, making it very difficult, not knowing where they go, all that kind of stuff.
在实施这种压制的那些人之间不说自明的事情吗？还是说，你认为真的存在某种对话，他们在其中进行协调，因为它正在发生，或者你认为真的有某种协调存在，因为我是这么想的。我认为他们一定在互相交谈，无论它是否是一种探讨，并讨论我们如何能进一步剥夺这些人的选举权，无论是将他们从名册中剔除、不让他们请假下班、让他们在大流行期间投票、使之变得非常困难、让他们不知道去哪里投票，所有诸如此类的事情。
This is a orchestrated attack on our system. And not illegal, right? Not illegal. They don't have to worry about an electronic trail on this, right? Like if you got their emails, they wouldn't be put in jail for doing this either, right? No, they had a meeting. They literally had a meeting. Yeah, right.
这是一场针对我们系统的有组织攻击。而且不违法，对吧？不违法。他们不必担心这会留下电子足迹，对吧？就像如果你拿到了他们的电子邮件，他们也不会因为做这个而坐牢，对吧？不，他们开过会。他们真的开过会。对啊，没错。
There were recordings of it where Justin Clark, who is their architect and is now the deputy campaign manager for the Trump campaign, said, voter suppression is how we win. I'm paraphrasing him, but he used all of those words in the sentence. So yes, this has been an orchestrated attempt, but let's understand that pre-1965, pre-voting rights act, you didn't have to do a lot of organizing because the law said black people can't vote, Latinos can't vote, Native Americans can't vote. So you had Jim Crow and its Western iterations. Post-65 to around 2008, you had this detente where Republicans understood that, well, Democrats
有当时的录音，他们的总设计师、现任特朗普竞选团队副竞选经理贾斯汀·克拉克（Justin Clark）说，选民压制是我们获胜的方式。我是对他的话进行意译，但他在这句话里用了所有这些词。所以是的，这是一次有组织的企图，但我们要明白，在1965年之前，在《投票权法案》之前，你不需要做太多的组织工作，因为法律规定黑人不能投票，拉丁裔不能投票，美洲原住民不能投票。所以当时有吉姆·克劳法及其西部演变形式。从65年之后到2008年左右，你经历了这样一段缓和期，当时共和党人明白——
at the beginning, and then eventually they became Republicans. But over time, those who were angry about people of color participating in elections, they realized that they could only do so much because the Voting Rights Act had stopped. In 2008, Barack Obama kind of put them on alert that, oh, my God, things are changing. So you saw states like North Carolina start to limit early voting and Sunday voting. They literally reduced Sunday voting because black people used it, it was called souls to the polls. They said, we're not going to let y'all do that anymore, so they limited it.
一开始是民主党人，后来他们变成了共和党人。但随着时间的推移，那些对有色人种参与选举感到愤怒的人意识到，他们能做的事情有限，因为《投票权法案》已经阻止了他们。2008年，巴拉克·奥巴马（Barack Obama）某种程度上给他们敲响了警钟，哦，天哪，事情正在改变。所以你看到像北卡罗来纳州这样的州开始限制提前投票和周日投票。他们真的减少了周日投票，因为黑人会利用它，这被称为“向投票站进发”（souls to the polls）。他们说，我们不再让你们这么干了，于是他们进行了限制。
Young people were voting too much, so they, in Florida, in Texas, you can't use your student ID to vote. You can use your gun license, but not your student ID. So then you get to 2013, and that was the moment of greatness for them, because that's when they eviscerated the Voting Rights Act, when they removed Section 5's effectiveness. And what that basically means is that, before 2013, you had to get permission to be racist in voting. You had to get permission to make it harder for people to vote.
年轻人投票太多了，所以在佛罗里达州、得克萨斯州，你不能用学生证投票。你可以用枪支许可证，但不能用学生证。然后到了2013年，那是他们的高光时刻，因为正是在那时，他们掏空了《投票权法案》，剥夺了第五条款的效力。这基本上意味着，在2013年之前，你在选举中要想表现得像个种族主义者是需要得到批准的。你得获得批准才能让人们投票更困难。
As of 2013, John Roberts said, well, we elected a black guy's president, racism is done, let's go party, you guys, you're good. And so what has happened since that time is that you saw this dramatic acceleration of voter suppression activities. They have been meeting about it. So groups like Alec, folks like Chris Kobach, who's running for the U.S. Senate, ran for governor, who's the secretary of state of Kansas, he believes that his mission in life is to push greater voter suppression.
截至2013年，约翰·罗伯茨（John Roberts）说，好吧，我们选了一个黑人当总统，种族主义结束了，大家去开派对吧，你们没事了。所以自那时以来发生的事情是，你看到了选民压制活动急剧加速。他们一直在开会商讨此事。因此像ALEC这样的组织，像正在竞选美国参议员、竞选过州长、曾任堪萨斯州国务卿的克里斯·科巴赫（Kris Kobach）这样的人，他坚信自己一生的使命就是推动更大的选民压制。
Brian Kemp, the secretary of state of Georgia, architect of voter suppression in the South. You've seen it play out in almost every state, but they do, they share information, they meet about it. And for this election, they have committed to raising $60 million, $20 million towards litigating, basically opposing any expansion of the right to vote. Meaning if you don't already use it, we don't want you to have it. And if you already have it, we're going to limit how effectively you can use it. They also plan to stand up an army of 50,000 poll monitors, who are going to be people who
佐治亚州国务卿布赖恩·肯普（Brian Kemp），南方选民压制的设计师。你看到它在几乎每个州上演，但他们确实这么做了，他们分享信息，开会讨论。对于这次选举，他们承诺筹集6000万美元，其中2000万美元用于诉讼，基本上是反对任何扩大投票权的举措。这意味着如果你还没有使用它，我们就不想让你拥有它。如果你已经拥有了它，我们要限制你使用它的效力。他们还计划建立一支由50,000名投票监督员组成的军队，这些人将是
basically challenge black and brown voters and question their right to vote, because it worked in 1981, and they were told not to do it for 35 years. They, shockingly, under the Trump administration, that consent decree was lifted. So now it's legal. So to Jason's point, they can legally stand in line and challenge people and try to scare them. And they might have a little band on their arm that says, off-duty ICE officer. Things like that can happen.
基本上对黑人和棕色人种选民提出质疑并盘问他们投票权的人，因为这在1981年奏效了，而且他们被告知35年内不准这么做。令人震惊的是，在特朗普政府领导下，这项同意令被解除。所以现在这合法的了。因此，正如杰森所说，他们可以合法地排队质问人们并试图吓唬他们。他们胳膊上可能还戴着个小袖标，上面写着“休班ICE（移民及海关执法局）官员”。诸如此类的事情都可能发生。
So all of these things are legal, which is why our work exists in the work of so many others. We work here to push back against what they intend, but we know what they intend because they had a meeting. Wow. So groups of citizens might be going around intimidating people in voting lines who aren't necessarily law enforcement, but are going around intimidating and they have arm bands on.
所以所有这些事情都是合法的，这就是为什么我们的工作以及许多其他人的工作得以存在。我们在这里努力回击他们的意图，但我们知道他们的意图，因为他们开过会。哇。所以公民团体可能会四处恐吓在投票队伍中并非必然是执法人员的人，但他们四处恐吓并且戴着袖标。
And I'm trying to think of what that reminds me of. I'm trying to think. Just give it some thought. We'll come back to you. Yeah. Just close your eyes. I wanted to know, is it a pipe dream to think that one day or maybe it's just, or is it impossible to think that we'll do what some other countries do and make it not only mandatory
我在想这让我想起了什么。我在想。稍微想一想。我们待会儿再告诉你。耶。闭上眼睛想想就行了。我想知道，认为总有一天或者也许只是，或者认为我们会像其他国家那样做不仅是强制
to vote, but it's a holiday? Why is that such a hard thing to pass? So I wrote this book called Our Time is Now. And part of what I wanted to do is let people understand just how complicated the United States has made its most basic right. And most nations, you don't have to register. You are automatically registered as a perk of citizenship. They put you on the rolls.
投票，而且把它变成一个节假日，这是一种白日梦吗？为什么这么难通过？所以我写了一本名为《我们当机立断》（Our Time is Now）的书。我想做的事情之一，就是让人们了解美国把其最基本的权利搞得有多么复杂。在大多数国家，你不需要注册。作为公民身份的福利，你是自动注册的。他们把你的名字列入名册。
You have to fight to get off to your point. If you live in Australia, it's the law you have to vote in most nations, you vote either on a Saturday or on a holiday. The United States has you vote on a Tuesday in the winter. After you've registered by, you know, in whatever state you happen to be in and you have to make sure you get there in time because the registration laws differ from place to place. All of this is solvable. There is a bill that passed and the very first bill passed under Speaker Nancy Pelosi, HR
为了被除名，你得去争取，正如你所说。如果你住在澳大利亚，法律规定你必须投票；在大多数国家，你要么在周六投票，要么在节假日投票。美国却让你在冬天的星期二投票。在你通过（你知道的）你所在的任何州的注册并确保及时赶到之后，因为各地注册法律各不相同。所有这些都是可以解决的。有一项法案通过了，在众议院议长南希·佩洛西（Nancy Pelosi）领导下通过的第一项法案，即HR
1. It would create all of the things we need to make democracy modern and useful in the United States when it comes to voting. And then you have HR 4 introduced by Terry Sewell and in honor of John Lewis, it should be the only, it should be the next bill that passes, but Mitch McConnell will not do it. It will restore the Voting Rights Act that says, not only are we going to create a national baseline for democracy, the right things to do, we're going to make certain that if somebody tries to do the wrong thing, we're going to stop them.
1。它将创造我们在美国投票时使民主现代化和实用化所需的所有条件。然后还有泰瑞·塞维尔（Terry Sewell）引入的HR 4，为纪念约翰·刘易斯（John Lewis），它本该是唯一的、本该是下一个通过的法案，但米奇·麦康奈尔（Mitch McConnell）就是不肯这么做。它将恢复《投票权法案》，该法案规定，我们不仅要为民主建立一个国家底线、做正确的事，我们还要确保如果有人试图做错误的事，我们要阻止他们。
But that means we have to win the White House and the Senate and hold the House. Are you shocked that Mitch McConnell is standing in the way of people participating in a democracy? So is that basically the main and only thing that we need to do in order to get all these common sense things into law is to just get control over the Senate, correct? So that's one. That's a big piece. We need to win the White House. We need to take the Senate.
但这意味着我们必须赢得白宫和参议院，并守住众议院。你对米奇·麦康奈尔阻挠人们参与民主感到震惊吗？所以这就是我们要把所有这些常识性的事情变成法律所需要做的主要且唯一的事情，就是夺回对参议院的控制权，对吗？所以这是一点。这是一个重要部分。我们需要赢得白宫。我们需要拿下参议院。
Most of this is statutory and very little of it is contestable under the Constitution. So that's first. The second piece is that we have to flip state legislatures. We need people to vote down ballot because this is a census here and I harp on the census all the time because it is the most important thing nobody cares about. The census is how we decide the next 10 years of leadership. People close their eyes and remember how great they felt in 2008 with the election of Barack Obama and the lovely two years that followed.
其中大部分是成文法，在宪法下几乎无可争议。所以这是第一点。第二个部分是，我们必须翻盘州议会。我们需要人们在选票下层进行投票，因为这是一个普查年，我一直在喋喋不休地谈论人口普查，因为它是最重要却无人关心的事情。人口普查决定了我们未来十年的领导层。人们闭上眼睛，回忆起2008年巴拉克·奥巴马当选以及随后的美好两年时感觉多好。
And then in 2010, we were all sobbing. Those of us who could pay attention because in 2011, Republicans drew the lines that took out Nancy Pelosi's speaker and replaced her with John Boehner. We lost our rights because people did not understand that gerrymandering, this thing we talk about, this spooky thing, it happens because of the census and because of who gets elected to state legislatures. So if we want to not only do it, but hold it, you can't just win the race. You've got to win the race and then you've got to burn down the field so they can't come
然后在2010年，我们都在哭泣。那些能够关注政治的我们，因为在2011年，共和党人重新划定了选区，把南希·佩洛西的议长职位弄没了，换成了约翰·博纳（John Boehner）。我们失去了权利，因为人们不明白选区划分不公——我们谈论的这个东西，这个可怕的东西——它的发生是因为人口普查，也是因为谁当选了州议会。所以如果我们不仅想做到这一点，还要守住成果，你不能仅仅赢得竞选。你必须赢得竞选，然后你必须把田地烧光，这样他们就无法回来
back and undo it. That's a terrible analogy. Sorry. No, it's good. But the gerrymandering, I mean, this is the thing that Eric Holder is spending a lot of time working on and Barack Obama is helping him with that as well. And it's incredibly important, I mean. Also something legal that on its face should be completely illegal.
撤销它。这是一个糟糕的比喻。抱歉。不，这很好。但选区划分不公，我的意思是，这是埃里克·霍尔德（Eric Holder）花大量时间致力于解决的事情，巴拉克·奥巴马也在协助他。这极其重要，我是说。这也是一件从表面上看完全违法的事。
Well, but you can't get there. So what I need people to understand is, yes, Eric Holder and the president have done extraordinary work to raise the specter of gerrymandering. And the thing is, what the Supreme Court has said is that gerrymandering that is political or partisan is permissible. In 2019, they said, as long as your constitution doesn't say you can't do it in a state, have that it. You can be as partisan as you want.
嗯，但你做不到。所以我需要人们理解的是，是的，埃里克·霍尔德和总统做出了非凡的工作，唤起人们对选区划分不公的警惕。问题在于，最高法院所说的是，政治或党派性质的选区划分不公是允许的。在2019年，他们表示，只要你们州的宪法没有说不能这样做，那就尽管去做。你想表现得多么党派化都可以。
But the only constitutional prohibition against gerrymandering is racial. Well, how do we know the races of the people in our states? The census. And so Donald Trump, in one of his sort of moments of prestidigitation, put out this memo saying he was going to make sure that undocumented immigrants were not going to be counted for reapportionment. And it's a terrible thing, but it's wholly and completely unconstitutional. What he's really trying to do is through Mitch McConnell, he's trying to accelerate the count
但唯一针对选区划分不公的宪法禁令是基于种族的。好吧，我们怎么知道我们州的人民的种族呢？人口普查。所以唐纳德·特朗普（Donald Trump）在他某种变戏法般的时刻，发布了一份备忘录，称他将确保无证移民不被计入重新分配名额的人数中。这是一件可怕的事情，但它是完全且彻底违宪的。他真正试图做的是通过米奇·麦康奈尔，试图加速人口普查的统计
through the census because of COVID, everything's been slowed down. Well, if you don't count everyone, if you speed through the process and people are left behind, then the Census Bureau has the authority to do something called imputation. Please stay awake. Imputation means that they can look at the census tracks that are next door. So let's say you've got one census track that's responsive. Everybody's telling who they are. They're doing all their work.
因为疫情，一切都被放慢了。好吧，如果你不统计所有人，如果你快进这个流程而把人们遗漏在外，那么人口普查局就有权做一件叫做“填补”（imputation）的事情。请保持清醒。填补意味着他们可以查看隔壁的普查小区。比方说，你有一个普查小区是做出回应的。每个人都在说出自己是谁。他们都在做所有的工作。
Another group has been scared out of doing it because they were told, if you fill out the census, you're going to be deported. If you fill out the census, you're going to be arrested. If you fill out the census, they're going to make you pay your child support. All of these specters that are out there trying to convince people of color not to fill the census. If those two census tracks are near each other, they will impute that the race of the people who did not respond is the same as the race of the people who did respond, which means
另一群人因为被告知“如果你填写人口普查，你就会被驱逐出境；如果你填写人口普查，你就会被捕；如果你填写人口普查，他们会逼你付抚养费”而吓得不敢配合。所有这些旨在说服有色人种不要填写人口普查的幽灵都在那里。如果这两个普查小区彼此靠近，他们就会推算那些没有回应的人的种族与那些有回应的人的种族相同，这意味着
black and brown communities suddenly look white. Well, the way this ties back to Trump is that if you can make communities of color look white and right now the response rate for people of color is down by almost 10%, then you can slash 10% of the people of color. Well when it comes time to gerrymander, you're not violating the prohibition against racial gerrymandering because you don't have any people of color to count. Wow. Right.
黑人和棕色人种社区突然看起来像白人了。好吧，这与特朗普的联系在于，如果你能让有色人种社区看起来像白人，而现在有色人种的回应率下降了近10%，那么你就可以削减10%的有色人种。当涉及到重新划定选区时，你并没有违反禁止基于种族的选区划分不公的规定，因为你根本没有统计到任何有色人种。哇。没错。
Oh gosh. Everyone who is within the sound of my voice, please God, fill out your census. Huh. Sean told me that his strongest census was census of smell, right? You were just saying. And sensibility. Oh no. Census and sensibility.
哦天哪。听到我声音的每一个人，求求你们，请填写你们的人口普查表。哈。肖恩告诉我，他最拿手的人口普查是气味普查，对吧？你刚才正说着呢。还有感性普查。哦不。理智与情感普查。
It's a play that we're doing about the census. Is it, I would love, I would love like you or you probably can't, but somebody like you to send out kind of like a playlist for people around voting day of like, this is who you should vote for. When you look at your ballot, just check all these boxes and you're good. But this is something we've talked about before. It's so important to get involved locally and how important all these elections, not just up top, but all the way through.
这是我们正在排演的一部关于人口普查的戏剧。是不是，我很希望，我很希望像你一样，或者你可能不行，但像你这样的人能发出一份播放列表，给投票日周围的人们列出：这就是你应该投票支持的人。当你看到选票时，只要勾选所有这些方框，你就搞定了。但这是我们之前讨论过的事情。参与地方事务是多么重要，所有这些选举又是多么重要，不仅仅是高层选举，而是一直延伸到底层。
It's so important. And it's taken me to this, I mean, I'm 50, I look like I'm 30, I'm taking words out of your mouth. No, you do. It's beautiful. It's not clear. It's taken me this long to realize how important these things are because, you know, look, what's that?
这太重要了。这让我意识到，我的意思是，我50岁，看起来像30岁，我抢了你的台词。不，你确实30岁。太美了。这还不清楚。我花了这么长时间才意识到这些事情有多重要，因为，听着，什么？
A skin toner? You're talking about, I mean, why start with a toner and that's a moisturizer. But the point is, because I'm not a maniac, the point is, I feel delinquent that it's taken me so long to start paying attention to what's happening. We just can't get complacent, right? Things look lined up pretty good, but we can't get lazy yet, right? So let me do three things first. So one on the list, the playlist, that's why we have political parties.
皮肤爽肤水？你在说的是，我的意思是，为什么从爽肤水开始，那是个保湿霜。但关键是，因为我不是疯子，关键是，我感到自己有愧，花了这么长时间才开始关注正在发生的事情。我们绝不能自满，对吧？事情看起来安排得挺好，但我们还不能偷懒，对吧？所以让我先做三件事。第一，关于那个列表，即播放列表，这就是我们为什么要有政党的原因。
The whole point of political parties is that the letter is supposed to give you the best sense of who you can vote for if you don't have time to check. And the reason you have primaries is to make sure that those who are paying attention give you the best person to vote for when you get to the general. And so while you won't get the exact list every time, depending on your political leanings, that's what the playlist is supposed to look like because we elect everything in America. And it becomes, I think it's both impertinent to try to tell people exactly who to vote for if you don't know enough about their community.
政党的全部意义就在于，如果你没有时间去查证，这个字母应该能为你提供关于你可以投票支持谁的最佳直觉。你举行初选的原因，就是为了确保那些关注政治的人在你到达大选投票站时为你提供最佳的投票人选。因此，虽然你不会每次都得到准确的名单，但根据你的政治倾向，这就是播放列表应该呈现的样子，因为我们在美国选举一切。而且它变成了一种，我认为试图告诉人们确切该投给谁是既冒昧的，如果你对他们的社区了解不够的话。
But that's why the shorthand of political parties exist. But of course it's completely valuable and terrible people make their way through. Will is kind of hoping that a flock of seagulls is on that playlist, aren't you? Yeah. There you go. I believe they'd be in the Green Party, but you know, depends on what they like. And then for Will, your point is do not feel bad. I mean, I want people to understand why it matters, but most of us never, we're never
但这就是政党简写存在的原因。但当然这是非常有价值的，也有糟糕的人混了进来。威尔有点希望那份播放列表里有一支海鸥乐队（Flock of Seagulls），对吧？对。给你。我相信他们会加入绿党，但你知道，这取决于他们喜欢什么。然后对威尔来说，你的观点是不要感到难过。我的意思是，我想让人们明白为什么这很重要，但我们大多数人从不，我们从未
taught this. Yeah. Trillions of dollars have been spent making sure we know who the president is, not just the campaigns, but we have entire, you know, oeuvre of shows and movies about the presidency. Nobody cares about a state legislator, except that the state legislator is the reason you will lose your reproductive choice. It's the decision that is made about whether you go to jail for five years or 50 years for crime.
被教导过这些。为了让我们知道谁是总统，人们花了几万亿美元，不仅是竞选活动，而且我们还有关于总统职位的整整一系列节目和电影。没有人关心州议员，除了州议员是你失去生殖选择权的罪魁祸首。它是关于你因犯罪而入狱5年还是50年的决定。
State legislators and local officials have a lot of power, but not a lot of money is spent trying to tell you about them. And we haven't had civic education in this country for about 40 years. So do not feel guilty. Just see this as a moment of expansion of your mind. So the last thing we do is vote by mail. Vote by mail, absolutely the thing to do, because we need to make certain one that it is safe vote.
州议员和地方官员拥有很大的权力，但并没有花太多钱来向你介绍他们。而且在这个国家，我们已经有大约40年没有公民教育了。所以不要感到内疚。把这看作是一个开阔眼界的时刻。所以我们做的最后一件事情是通过邮寄投票。绝对应该通过邮寄投票，因为我们需要确保第一，这是安全的投票。
So if you have vote by mail and 34 states let you vote by mail with no excuses, 16 states require an excuse of some kind, but every state is capable of vote by mail. So if you live in a state where they're already good with it, use it, get it done, be happy. It's not just because it's the safest way to get votes in. It's also a way that you can audit the ballots. So in a lot of states, if you want to make sure that there is no shenanigans, vote by mail gives you a chance to go back and check and make sure that what happened happened. But it's also critical for people who don't have the option to vote by mail.
所以如果你有邮寄投票，34个州允许你无理由邮寄投票，16个州要求某种理由，但每个州都有能力实行邮寄投票。所以如果你住在一个对这很习惯的州，那就用它，搞定它，开开心心的。这不仅是因为这是最安全获得选票的方式。这也是一种你可以对选票进行审计的方式。因此在许多州，如果你想确保没有猫腻，邮寄投票给了你回去检查并确保发生的事情确实发生的机会。但对于那些没有邮寄投票选择权的人来说，这也至关重要。
There are a lot of folks who are essential workers, shift workers. They don't get a choice of when they get off work. If they can't get to their polling place, if they don't get to vote by mail, that's the only way they're going to get to vote. And then the same thing is true if you're disabled, if you have a language barrier, or if you're homeless, if you've been displaced by COVID because Mitch McConnell in the Senate refuses to do anything about the evictions that are about to sweep this country. All of those people are going to need to vote in person.
有很多人是核心行业员工、轮班工人。他们没有选择下班时间的选择权。如果他们去不了投票站，如果他们不能邮寄投票，那是他们投票的唯一途径。如果你身体残疾、有语言障碍、或是无家可归，如果你因新冠疫情而流离失所，因为参议院的米奇·麦康奈尔拒绝采取任何行动来应对即将席卷这个国家的驱逐潮，同样的情况也适用。所有这些人将需要亲自投票。
Everyone who votes by mail creates a safe space in line for the person who doesn't have a choice. There are a lot of folks like me who would try to vote by mail, but my mail and ballot, when it finally arrived, filled it out, it was really long. I went to put it in the return envelope and it was sealed shut. And under Georgia law, I could not open it. If I could steam it open, I could use it. But if I ripped it in any way, I could not use it.
每一个通过邮寄投票的人，都为那些没有选择的人在队伍中创造了一个安全的空间。有很多像我这样的人会尝试邮寄投票，但我的邮寄选票真正送达时，我填好了，它真的很长。我去把它塞进回邮信封时，信封已经封死了。根据佐治亚州的法律，我无法打开它。如果我能用蒸汽把它熏开，我还能用。但如果我有任何撕裂，我就不能用了。
I requested a replacement envelope. It never showed up. And so I had to vote in person. That is unbelievable. So she had to drive down on that day. I mean, that's pretty crafty, right? I mean, yeah, yeah, we'll give you a mail and ballot, not a problem. But then they seal the envelope, I mean, they just sent them all, they sent them all sealed.
我申请了替换信封。它压根没寄到。所以我不得不亲自去投票。这太不可思议了。所以她那天不得不开车赶去。我的意思是，这挺狡猾的，对吧？我的意思是，耶，耶，我们给你一张邮寄选票，没问题。但随后他们封死信封，我的意思是，他们把所有的信封都寄出来了，寄过来时都是封好的。
How cynical is it when you hear, you hear Trump and you, or you see his tweets about rigged election because the mail in vote and blah, blah, blah, knowing that that's how he votes. Well, not only is it how he votes, this is the same man who said in a tweet, absentee ballots are safe, they're not subject to fraud, they're fantastic, but mail in voting is fraudulent and terrible. It's the same thing. It's the exact same thing.
当你听到特朗普说，或是看到他的推文宣称因为邮寄选票而导致选举被操纵等等，而明知这也是他自己的投票方式时，这有多虚伪？嗯，不仅这是他的投票方式，这就是同一个人，他在一条推文中说，缺席选票是安全的，它们不受欺诈影响，它们太棒了，但邮寄投票是欺诈性的、糟糕的。这完全是一回事。这完全是一回事。
And so I don't know how much of it is, and I mean, there's a bit of ignorance that pervades a lot of his whining. And in this case, I know it's shocking, I don't mean to throw you guys off, but vote by mail is safe. It is not subject to fraud. It does not happen with any degree of density or worry. And so voting by mail, if you can do it and do it as fast as you can, because they are trying to take down the post office, he is doing his best to underfund and undermine the
所以我不知道其中有多少是，我的意思是，他的许多抱怨中弥漫着一定程度的无知。在这种情况下，我知道这很震惊，我不是故意让你们感到意外，但邮寄投票是安全的。它不受欺诈影响。它不会以任何程度的密集或担忧发生。所以如果你能邮寄投票，就尽快去做，因为他们正试图搞垮邮政局，他正竭尽全力削减资金和破坏
post office. So as soon as you can vote by mail, do so because that gets your ballot counted. But the thing is, no matter what he tries, everyone can still vote in person on election day, unless you live in one of the five states that do only vote by mail, but even they make provisions. But if people think that there are still existing problems, barriers, it's going to be a waste of my time to spend four hours in line or take the day off from work to vote. Then they're just going to say, screw it, at the end of the day, I'm just one vote anyway,
邮政局。所以只要你能邮寄投票，就赶紧去，因为这样你的选票才能被统计。但关键是，无论他怎么尝试，每个人仍然可以在选举日亲自投票，除非你住在仅限邮寄投票的那五个州之一，但即使是他们也有相关规定。但如果人们认为仍然存在现存的问题、障碍，觉得花四个小时排队或请一天假去投票是在浪费时间。那么他们就会说，去他的，反正我只是一张选票，
and I'm not going to vote. Like, that's the problem. So when will they know, actually, I don't need to worry about that. It is going to be worth my time, and I am going to go vote. But also, right. But also, to that point, like, sorry to go back to the national holiday, like making election day a national paid holiday. Why don't we start with, like, I don't know, Jeff Bezos or some of these huge corporations
我才不投呢。这就是问题所在。所以他们什么时候才能真正明白，我不需要担心这个。这绝对值得我花时间，我要去投票。但还有，对。但同时，说到这一点，抱歉回到全国假期的那个话题，比如把选举日定为一个全国带薪假期。为什么我们不从，我不知道，杰夫·贝索斯（Jeff Bezos）或一些大公司开始
if it's not a law, I would be like, guys, go vote, I'll pay for the day. Like, why don't we start at a corporate level instead of a government level? Well, we have to do all of the above. So Fair Fight is working with corporations here in Georgia. We've got an Arthur Blank to let those who work for him, they're giving them time off to vote, and we're working with a number of national corporations to get them to do just that. But here's the reason I don't want people to think that because it's not solved that
如果这不是法律，我会说，伙计们，去投票吧，这一天我付工资。为什么我们不从公司层面而不是政府层面开始呢？嗯，我们必须双管齐下。所以“公正之战”正在与佐治亚州的各大公司合作。我们有阿瑟·布兰克（Arthur Blank）让为他工作的人带薪投票，我们正与许多跨国公司合作，让他们也这么做。但这就是为什么我不希望人们认为因为问题尚未解决，
they shouldn't vote. That's the point. The point is, to just make you believe your vote doesn't count, 73,000 people changed America in 2014. 10,000 people in Wisconsin voted in a certain way and changed the future of America. 24,000 in Michigan, around 30,000, about 40,000 in Pennsylvania. So let's be clear, every vote does count. 54,723 people are the reason I'm not the governor.
他们就不应该去投票。这就是关键所在。关键是，只是为了让你相信你的投票不重要——2014年，73,000人改变了美国。威斯康星州有10,000人以某种方式投票并改变了美国的未来。密歇根州有24,000人，宾夕法尼亚州大约30,000人，大约40,000人。所以我们要明确，每一票都很重要。54,723人就是我没能当选州长的原因。
I know one of the reasons they didn't get to vote, but if you can make it through the gauntlet, do it. And the last thing I'll say is this, black people stand in line longer than anyone else in America when it comes to voting. If we can do it, so can you. The reality is we only get the change we're willing to fight for, and the only way we can fight Republicans and win is if we win this election, because they're not going to give in.
我知道他们没能投票的原因之一，但如果你能闯过重重关卡，就去投吧。最后我要说的是这个。黑人在美国投票时排队的时间比其他人都要长。如果我们能做到，你也能。现实情况是，我们只能得到我们愿意为之奋斗的改变，而我们能够与共和党人斗争并取胜的唯一途径就是赢得这次选举，因为他们是不会妥协的。
We can sue them and they will counter sue, but we can make it easier and we can make people more aware and we can provide the help you need. But the only solution to voter suppression is a new president and a new Senate and new legislators. And so I created Fair Fight to work on the elections and Fair Count is the other organization to work on the census because I am crafty. I try to think about what the next thing that you're going to do to hurt me is. And so I try to figure that thing out too, because I'm from Mississippi and I've been
我们可以起诉他们，他们会反诉，但我们可以让投票变得更容易，我们可以提高人们的意识，我们可以提供你需要的帮助。然而，解决选民压制的唯一方案是一个新总统、一个新参议院和新议员。所以我创立了“公正之战”来处理选举，而“公正统计”（Fair Count）是另一个致力于人口普查的组织，因为我很狡猾。我试图思考你接下来要做什么来伤害我。所以我也会设法弄清楚那一招，因为我来自密西西比州，我一直都是
black my whole life. So I don't take anything for granted. But I need us all to operate with that mindset that we can't just win this thing and we can't be defeated by this thing. I should still be curled in the fetal position from 2018. Yeah, right. Right. It's astonishing that you aren't.
我一生都是黑人。所以我不会把任何事情视为理所当然。但我需要我们所有人都带着这种心态行事：我们不能只靠赢得这场斗争，我们也不会被这件事打败。我本该因为2018年的事情而蜷缩在胎儿的状态里。是的，没错。没错。你居然没有这样，这真令人惊讶。
Stacey, I just want to say thank you so much for educating me and Will and Jason and all our listeners about voter suppression and what that means and everything that goes with it. So for everybody listening on a serious note, please get out and vote. Your voice matters now more than ever. It's such an important election. Please use your voice. It's the only thing we have.
斯黛西，我只想说非常感谢你向我、威尔、杰森以及我们所有的听众普及了选民压制、它的含义以及与之相关的一切。所以对于所有在认真听节目的朋友们，请出门投票。你的声音现在比以往任何时候都更加重要。这是一场如此重要的选举。请发出你的声音。这是我们仅有的武器。
Vote, vote, vote. It's a very serious thing. So now I'd like to take a hard left turn and ask you a question that I've always wanted to know. I heard you're a fan of Star Trek. Is that true? Yes. I wanted to know what you think of the movies that JJ Abrams directed.
投票，投票，投票。这是一件非常严肃的事情。那么现在我想来个急转弯，问你一个我一直想知道的问题。我听说你是《星际迷航》的粉丝。这是真的吗？是的。我想知道你对J·J·艾布拉姆斯导演的电影有什么看法。
Are you a fan? I am actually. I think he's done an amazing job of recasting the story. It's hard to come in this far into a franchise, but the way he reimagined it so that people could enter and enjoy is fantastic. And he and Katie have both been very supportive of the work we do, too. Yes, I know. But I liked him before that.
你是粉丝吗？我其实是。我认为他在重塑这个故事方面做了一项了不起的工作。在这样一个拥有悠久历史的系列中接手是很难的，但他重新构思的方式让人们能够轻松入坑并乐在其中，这太棒了。而且他和凯蒂都非常支持我们所做的工作。是的，我知道。但我在这之前就喜欢他了。
I loved him with alias. Yeah. Why would somebody be a Star Trek fan and not a Star Wars fan or a fan of both? But a more, more of a, you say you're more of a Star Trek than Star Wars. What's the difference? Star Trek is science fiction and Star Wars uses science, but it's more fantasy. Star Wars doesn't, it happens in space, but it doesn't really think about what's about physics and astrophysics and astronomy.
我从《双面女间谍》开始就爱上他了。是的。为什么会有人成为《星际迷航》的粉丝而不是《星球大战》的粉丝，或者两者都是粉丝？但你更偏向于《星际迷航》而不是《星球大战》。有什么区别？《星际迷航》是科幻小说，而《星球大战》运用了科学，但它更偏向奇幻。《星球大战》不，它发生在太空，但它并不真正考虑物理学、天体物理学和天文学。
Star Trek is for nerds who love physics. Yeah. I mean, you could take the narrative of Star Wars, which is fantastic, but you could put it in another place. Star Trek requires that you be in space. It requires that you have this frame of transportation and this way of thinking about the rest of the universe. I remember seeing the Wrath of Khan.
《星际迷航》是属于热爱物理学的书呆子的。是的。我的意思是，你可以把《星球大战》的叙事拿走，那棒极了，但你可以把它放在另一个地方。《星际迷航》要求你身处太空。它要求你有这种传输框架和看待宇宙其余部分的独特方式。我还记得看《可汗怒吼》时的情景。
Yes, the Wrath of Khan is amazing. I remember seeing it in the theaters. Wrath of Khan. Yeah, that's a good story. And then how does J.J. do both? I don't know. He did both, right?
是的，《可汗怒吼》太棒了。我记得在电影院看过它。可汗怒吼。是的，那是个好故事。然后J·J是怎么把这两者都拍好的？我不知道。他两部都拍了，对吧？
I mean, J.J. Yeah, he did. Star Wars and Star Trek. Yeah. I don't know. I have a lot of time. How do you do that? I mean, that should be disallowed, right?
我是说，J·J。是的，他拍了。《星球大战》和《星际迷航》。是的。我不知道。我有的是时间。你怎么做到的？我的意思是，这应该是不被允许的吧？
By the purists. We are a peaceful race. We will allow you to come from other spaces. I am a Star Trek person who appreciates Star Wars. I am not a Star Wars fan. Are you a Trekkie? Yes. You are.
对于纯粹主义者来说。我们是一个爱好和平的种族。我们允许你从其他空间来。我是一个欣赏《星球大战》的《星际迷航》迷。我不是《星球大战》的粉丝。你是Trekkie吗？是的。你是。
Wow, right off the bat. Oh boy. Listener, she just put up the, what is it? The Vulcan. Vulcan? Was Nichelle Nichols like when you were a girl, you're like, oh my God, wow. So I didn't because she was, it's a terrible story, but we didn't have CBS when I was growing up, so I couldn't have watched Star Trek because it was on CBS.
哇，一上来就来了。哦天哪。听众朋友们，她刚刚摆出了，那是什么？瓦肯举手礼。瓦肯？当你是小女孩的时候，尼谢尔·尼科尔斯就像是，天哪，哇。所以我没有，因为她，这是一个糟糕的故事，但我们小时候没有CBS，所以我不可能看《星际迷航》，因为它是在CBS上播出的。
But I did see her in an airport when I was running for governor and lost all of my mind. I'm sure. I'm sure. Is there anybody in the Senate or the House of Representatives that you have not met, that you would love to meet and would dork out as much as if you were trapped in an elevator with William Shatner? No. No.
但我在竞选州长时确实在机场见过她，当时我简直激动的快疯了。我确信。我确信。参议院或众议院里有没有谁是你还没见过，但你特别想见，而且会像被困在电梯里和威廉·夏特纳在一起一样狂热追星的？没有。没有。
There's nobody you'd fan out on in government. I've gotten to meet most of my governmental heroes. I appreciate meeting all of them. But if you put William Shatner, Kate Mulgrew, Avery Brooks, Scott Bakula, and my God. Scott Bakula. Well, he was the captain of Enterprise. Got it. He's such a nice guy.
在政府里没有哪个官员能让你变成狂热粉丝。我几乎见过了我所有的政府英雄。我很感激能见到他们所有人。但是如果你把威廉·夏特纳、凯特·穆格鲁、埃弗里·布鲁克斯、斯科特·巴库拉，天哪。斯科特·巴库拉。哦，他是《企业号》的船长。明白了。他是个非常好的人。
You would love him. And Patrick Stewart, who of course is the quintessential captain of this era. I would probably pass out. Truly. Really? Yeah. My God. I love it.
你会喜欢他的。还有帕特里克·斯图尔特，他当然是这个时代最典型的舰长。我可能会晕倒。真的。真的吗？是的。天哪。我太喜欢了。
Not a lot of people know that Scott Bakula, right? So he was the captain of one of those ships and it crashed in New Orleans and then he became a policeman in New Orleans, right? Isn't that how NCIS New Orleans happens? That's going to be the prequel, right? Yeah. Interesting fact, everybody. Stacy is the, she is also Selena Montgomery.
没多少人知道斯科特·巴库拉，对吧？所以他是其中一艘飞船的船长，飞船在新奥尔良坠毁了，然后他成了新奥尔良的警察，对吧？《海军罪案调查处：新奥尔良》不就是这么来的吗？那将是前传，对吧？是的。有趣的事实，各位。斯黛西，她，她也是塞丽娜·蒙哥马利。
Yes. Who writes romantic suspense novels. Yeah. And, and quite a few of them. When is the last time you wrote one of those? Do we have one to look forward to? I want to hear about why you want to write these things. I've got, I've got, I could do a whole nother hour on this.
是的。她写浪漫悬疑小说。是的。而且数量还真不少。你上次写是什么时候？我们还有新书可以期待吗？我想听听你为什么想写这些东西。我有，我有，我能就这个再聊整整一个小时。
So wrote my first one during law school. It was actually going to be a spy novel, but I was told that publishers did not publish spy novels by or about women. And if you think about it, there have been no major women as espionage writers. But I also remembered General Hospital, Luke and Laura, Robert Nanoscorpio, and I watched a lot of all of the James Bond movies. So I just made my spies fall in love, killed the same number of people. Someone bought the book, then they kept buying them.
所以我读法学院时写了第一本。它本来应该是一部间谍小说，但我被告知出版商不出版女性创作或以女性为主角的间谍小说。如果你想想看，过去没有哪个主要的女性间谍小说家。但我也想到了《综合医院》的卢克和劳拉、罗伯特·纳诺斯科皮奥，而且我看了很多詹姆斯·邦德的电影。所以我只是让我笔下的间谍坠入爱河，杀了同样数量的人。有人买这本书，然后他们就一直买。
And then my last book was in 2010. I'd moved out of espionage into just action adventure. Although I did do a serial killer romance novel. And then my last novel was written right before I became democratic leader and I started a small business that was a finance company. And so that was the last time I wrote a book, but I owe one more book because it's the, I've forgotten to do the, I haven't forgotten. I've neglected to do the third book in the trilogy and my sister, every so often,
然后我的最后一本书是在2010年。我从间谍题材转向了纯粹的动作冒险。虽然我确实写过一本连环杀手浪漫小说。然后我的最后一部小说是在我成为民主党领袖之前不久写的，当时我创办了一家小型金融公司。所以那是最后一次写书，但我还欠一本书，因为这是，我忘了做，我没忘。我忽略了写三部曲中的第三本书，我姐姐每隔一段时间，
every major holiday asked me when I'm going to get it done. So I'm going to get it done. Well, now that the cat's out of the bag with the pseudonym, I mean, are you going to use Selena Montgomery anymore? Or is it just Stacy Abrams writes this suspense novel? I was never ashamed of the, of writing romance. I was writing tax articles at the exact same time. And this was at the advent of Google.
每个重大节日都会问我什么时候能写完。所以我一定会把它写完。好吧，既然用了笔名这个秘密已经泄露了，我的意思是，你还会用塞丽娜·蒙哥马利吗？还是说以后只有斯黛西·艾布拉姆斯来写悬疑小说？我从来没有为写言情小说感到羞耻。我当时在写税务文章，而且正好是在谷歌刚出现的时候。
So if you Google my name, you got the operational dissonance of the unrelated business income tax exemption, an article I'd written in high school on Mesopotamian astronomy and my romance novel. Please make that a book. Please write that in a full book and a movie. No one's going to read a romance novel by Alan Greenspan. So I had to have a different name for my romance to separate it from my more pedestrian efforts and tax books.
所以如果你在谷歌上搜我的名字，你会发现不相关企业所得税豁免的操作失调，我还在高中时写过一篇关于美索不达米亚天文学的文章，以及我的言情小说。请把它出一本书吧。请把它写成一本完整的书和一部电影。没有人会读艾伦·格林斯潘写的言情小说。所以我必须为我的言情小说起一个不同的名字，以便把它和我在税务书籍上那些更枯燥的努力区分开来。
But what about going forward? Are you going to write them under Stacy Abrams? No, I mean, she's a brand. Selena is a brand and people would, but I'm happy to, my picture was in all the books. I love it. That's awesome. You've been incredible to join us.
但接下来呢？你会用斯黛西·艾布拉姆斯的名字来写吗？不，我的意思是，她是一个品牌。塞丽娜是一个品牌，人们会，但我很高兴，我的照片在所有的书里。我太喜欢了。这太棒了。你能来参加我们的节目真是太不可思议了。
I can't thank you enough. I wish you all the luck and support and love in the world going forward and hope to see a whole lot more of you in the future. This has been the most fun. Thank you all three of you for your art, your activism, and for letting me join you today. Thank you, Stacy. Thank you so much.
我怎么感谢你都不够。祝你未来一切顺利，得到所有的支持和爱，并希望在未来看到你更多地出现。这真是太有趣了。谢谢你们三位展示你们的艺术、积极行动，并让我今天加入你们。谢谢你，斯黛西。非常感谢。
Have a great day. Take care guys. Bye. She's just an angel, right? Her and her life are the perfect thing to do a movie for. That was fun, Matt. Boy, she's great. That is so good to know.
祝你有美好的一天。保重，伙计们。拜拜。她简直是个天使，对吧？她和她的人生是拍电影的绝佳题材。那太有趣了，马特。天哪，她太棒了。能知道这些太好了。
I mean, there's so much stuff when it comes to voter suppression and all of that. Like, how enlightening was that? I learned so much. How do we not spend so much more money and resources and time? How do we not throw it at elections? They couldn't be more important. And we know why because the answer is for certain people, they know that educated people or people who know what they're doing
我的意思是，当涉及到选民压制以及所有这些事情时，有太多内容了。这有多具有启发性？我学到了太多。我们怎么能不花更多的钱、资源和时间呢？我们怎么能不把它们投入到选举中呢？它们再重要不过了。我们知道原因，因为答案是对于某些人来说，他们知道受过教育的人或者知道自己在做什么的人
or people being allowed to vote is bad for them. And we know who that is. Well, also, there's no consequences. You would think that the consequences for trying to take somebody's right to vote would be at a minimum 10 years in jail. When does that happen? Immediately. In fact, it is legal.
或者被允许投票的人对他们是不利的。我们知道那是谁。好吧，同样，也没有什么后果。你会认为试图剥夺某人投票权的后果至少是判处10年监禁。什么时候才会发生？立刻。事实上，那是合法的。
Well, the thing is the way that they broke it down by the rigging of the census and sort of making, you know, that that has become the way that they can do it and they can get away with it in broad daylight. But that's why I'm really passionate about these corporations stepping in and but all the corporations, like as many as possible, stepping in and making it a paid holiday for that. That's a great way to start, you know. Yeah, exactly.
嗯，问题是他们通过操纵人口普查来分解这一切的方式，某种程度上让，你知道的，这已经成为他们可以做到这一点并且在光天化日之下逍遥法外的方式。但这就是为什么我对这些大公司介入感到非常热情，而且是所有大公司，尽可能多的公司，介入并将其定为带薪假。这是一个很好的开始，你知道的。是的，完全正确。
And right now there's so much societal pressure to do the right thing at a corporate level. You can see it with Black Lives Matter, not to be a cynic about that at all, but it's so nice that it is forcing the hand of a lot of these corporations, even if they're doing it for hearts and minds and the optics of it, whatever it is, these great things are getting pushed through and maybe this could piggyback on that. Yeah, exactly. If we can kind of this sort of corporate guilt can be taken from what's going on now
而现在社会上有很大的压力要在企业层面做正确的事情。你可以从“黑命贵”运动中看到这一点，对此并不是要当个愤世嫉俗的人，但这太棒了，它迫使许多企业采取行动，即使他们这么做是为了赢得民心和公关形象，无论出于什么原因，这些伟大的事情正在被推行，也许这可以顺水推舟。是的，完全正确。如果我们能把这种企业负罪感从现在发生的事情中转移开
and we can administer that on to voter suppression, then that would be amazing. Yeah. Yeah. Very, very lucky to have her. Yeah, good get, dude. Yeah, right? That was awesome. I loved it.
并将其应用到选民压制上，那将是了不起的。是的。是的。非常、非常幸运能请到她。是的，好样的，老兄。对吧？太棒了。我太喜欢了。
I loved it. Learned so much. I got something I really want to say to you guys and it goes a little like this. Bye. Pasta. That's not your thing. Smart. Yes.
我太喜欢了。学到了很多。我有些话真的很想对你们说，大致是这样的。拜拜。意大利面。那不是你的风格。聪明。是的。
Smart. Yes. Smart. Yes. Smart. Yes. Smart. Yes.
聪明。是的。聪明。是的。聪明。是的。聪明。是的。
Smart. Yes. Smart. Yes. Smart. Yes. Smart. Yes. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
聪明。是的。聪明。是的。聪明。是的。聪明。是的。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。